as the old saying goes good things come
to those who wait
and that's certainly the case for
captain tom moore a world war
ii veteran first he was promoted to
colonel after he raised millions of
pounds for the british national health
service with a charity
walk around his garden now his
accomplishments have been recognized by
royalty
and that means this 100 year old is the
united kingdom's
newest knight amid the pandemic
queen elizabeth seldom takes part in
official duties
but this is a unique situation in unique
times
for a unique man captain tom moore a
world war ii veteran
a fundraising hero and a national icon
now britain's longest-serving monarch
knighted him allowing him to carry the
title
sir thomas moore
the ceremony was held under strict
coronavirus pandemic protocols
on the grounds of winslow castle
following social distancing rules
moore captured the hearts of many when
prior to his 100th birthday
he walked 100 laps in his garden raising
over 33 million pounds for health
workers
and prompting prime minister boris
johnson to nominate him for knighthood
prior to the ceremony moore was worried
about only one thing
i'm absolutely overwhelmed by that i
mean
everybody gets the chance to see the
queen is it
i think that's going to be absolutely
marvelous for me
and are you still worried about um
kneeling down and getting up
i don't if i kneel down i'll never get
up again
luckily for more he did not have to
kneel during the ceremony